estas imágenes publicadas por las
fuerzas de defensa israelíes el sábado
pretenden mostrar el momento en que tres
drones disparados por el grupo libanés
hezbollah fueron derribados dijeron que
los drones se dirigían al campo de gas
de caris a menos de 100 kilómetros de
las costas de israel hezbollah confirmó
el incidente el sábado sin decir que los
drones habían sido interceptados el
sábado por la tarde 3 drones desarmados
fueron lanzados hacia el disputado
campus de caris para realizar misiones
de reconocimiento la misión fue cumplida
y el mensaje fue recibido líbano a
israel que comparten fronteras se han
enfrentado en los últimos años por los
recursos del mar las tensiones
aumentaron el mes pasado cuando un buque
fletado por israel operado por una
empresa griega entró en el campo de
caris e instaló una plataforma
provocando una rápida respuesta des bola
télam
la empresa griega y sus propietarios
deben saber que son socios de la
agresión que se está produciendo en el
líbano en estos momentos
nuestra la instó además a las
autoridades israelíes a esperar a que
las negociaciones que cuentan con la
mediación de eeuu den sus resultados las
negociaciones se han estancado en los
últimos años mientras los dos países que
están oficialmente en guerra se disputan
las lucrativas reservas de energía